اذا مشاهدينا كما تابعنا واياكم ذوي
انفجارات
كبيره وسماع لرشقات
الرصاص في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
استمعنا واياكم اليها قبل قليل
وهذا دوي انفجار كبير ايضا اخر
اذا هذه هي الصوره من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطومه هي صوره متكرره يعني حقيقه خلال
هذا الاسبوع منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباكات صور
واصوات اطلاق الرصاص بهذا الشكل
الانفجارات ايضا حتى الكبيره
في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بالقرب
المحيط القياده العامه للجيش في الخرطومه
التي يسيطر عليها الجيش كما نشر فيديو قبل
قليل ايضا
من امام القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات